there's a developing story happening in
Argentina right now back in 2018
Argentina took a 57 billion dollar loan
from the IMF that loan was to cover all
sorts of different obligations that they
had they only received about 44 billion
or so of the 57 billion the predecessor
to that president ended up saying stop
we don't want the rest of the money well
now payments are due and the Argentinian
government is renegotiating that loan
and its terms with the IMF but the imf's
trying to do something a little sneaky
they're trying to sneak in some language
that would actually slow down and
potentially hamper the adoption of
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies in the
country here's the exact language that
is in the bill it says that the national
government for a better Safeguard of
financial stability will discourage the
use of cryptocurrencies in the
prevention of Fraud and informality in
the same way the digitization of
payments will have official incentives
and additional protection will be given
to the financial consumer now of course
this is wild the free market should be
decide exciting what technologies are
used what money is used why is the IMF
somebody that doesn't know anything
about the Argentinian people and what
they want why are they trying to
implement this in the renegotiation of
the loan ultimately the people are
making their voice heard there's photo
after photo after photo of them going
out into the streets and saying we don't
want this ultimately what we are
watching is a free market competition
between technologies that market should
determine who the winner is and so
whether this actually goes through or
not the people of Argentina who live in
an environment with around 50 percent
annual inflation they realize that they
need new technologies they need new
assets they need a different path to get
to a world of Financial Security and
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency serve as one
of those options they don't want to be
cut off from it kudos to the Argentinian
people I tend to think that their voice
will prevail and Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies will continue to be
adopted in a country that needs it most
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time